hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren letztens haben Sirio und ich ja
bereits McDonald's mit Burger King
verglichen der ist größer dicker sieht
frischer aus der dagegen ist ein
bisschen tot aber ich habe mich trotzdem
für den entschieden jetzt gerade bereits
im Titel eingeblendet denn heute
bestellen wird also wir haben halt schon
bestellt ich habe Produkte bei
McDonald's bestellt die man sonst
eigentlich niemals
bestellen würde
ich weiß du liebst mich nicht
gegessen kannst du Sachen dabei wie ein
Mac double Chili Cheese ich wusste nicht
gibt ich habe ein snackssalat classic
wer ist Salat bei McDonald's ich habe
Frucht Quatsch das ist eine heiße Tasche
mit Erdbeergeschmack irgendwie also
Apfeltaschen mit Erdbeeren ich habe Senf
bestellt in Buttermilch Ranch Dip die
Leo Fisch ein apfeltüte und noch ein
paar andere Produkte sind was willst du
anfangen boah ich würde sagen das
Gesundheit am Ende
kann es sein dass du dumm bist
verpackungstechnisch genauso wie ein
Hamburger Cheeseburger Chickenburger
ziemlich schlecht das ist der Burger
tot aus
der Spruch kann ich von dem da
halt deine Schnauze wenn man das Patty
oben runter nimmt ist war nein da sind
gewisse Punkten drauf Nelson Chilis Bro
jalapenos
passt
nein
Tod okay
[Musik]
wie normal
ja aber irgendwie ohne alles so ohne
Soße schlechter als ein Cheeseburger
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
Produkt und zwar
genau
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
ich kann sowas nicht essen
und wenn diese Erdbeergelee Zuckermasse
an den Zähnen hängenbedingte frittierten
überlegen Sirius zu einer der spielt
doch seinen mundeinnahmen sind noch mal
mit Cola aus machen wir weiter mit dem
nächsten Produkt und zwar dem Mac plant
der kommt im Vergleich zum MC double
Chili Cheats Jalapeno Chili Boppard
cheese wenigstens in so einem Pappkarton
und sieht so aus
wenigstens der fühlt man sich mehr lieb
bei McDonald's
[Musik]
also sagen gleich aber tot also wenn das
Fleisch hier drin nicht vegan wäre
sondern richtiges Fleisch durch den
Burger auch kacke finden also es liegt
am wenigsten am Fleisch an dieser
veganen Fleisch Alternative sondern am
meisten wirklich an diesem Soßen Gemisch
da drauf also auch überhaupt nicht mein
Teil als nächstes machen wir weiter mit
der Bio Apfel Tüte die habe ich glaube
ich als Kind mal bestellt bei McDonald's
gegeben
ja null
ja Äpfel halten
sind auf jeden Fall ein bisschen mehlig
die Stimme Äpfeln aber meinst du meinst
sie haben zugefügt weiß McDonald's
[Musik]
machen wir jetzt allerdings weiter mit
einem Getränk und zwar dem Tropicana
Orangensaft ich habe noch nie bei
McDonald's einen Orangensaft bestellt
generell sind das alles Produkte die
habe ich in den letzten locker zehn
Jahren nicht dort bestellt okay Video
Fischen aber getestet letztens bestimmt
als Gegenstück Burger King also die
anderen Sachen habe ich alle noch nie
bestellt fast habe ich noch nie gegessen
heute ist erstmal aber den habe ich
schon mal gegessen aber da war der hatte
der andere Rezeptur Sprachen lernen
Babbel
ja aber nicht
Orangensaft
[Musik]
okay eigentlich ich glaube sogar
am Flughafen und sowas super
teuer
machen wir jetzt weiter mit Sirius
Lieblings Burger
das Problem ist der sieht wirklich sehr
sehr frech aus der sieht aus
[Musik]
es ist auf jeden Fall der amerikanische
Burger bei McDonald's
um no joke ich habe ihn mir wirklich
schlimmer vorgestellt als jetzt gerade
wo ich rein gebissen habe ist okay ne
weil ich dachte dieses Fleisch ist so C
und eine Zwiebel hatte zum Glück nicht
im Maul jetzt aber die Soße schmeckt
auch eigentlich ganz okay schmeckt wie
so eine Currywurst Soße aber es wäre
definitiv immer noch der letzte Burger
den ich da bestellen würde machen wir
nun weiter mit dem Mac plant Nuggets die
haben wir auch in unserem
Vergleichsvideo von McDonald's und
Burger King
wir haben ja da schon gegessen
allerdings haben wir die dort in süßes
Soße getunkt denn sie ist auch so meine
Sixpack
en
[Musik]
8000 € für die Kamera raus wenn das Ding
kann ich fokussieren auf jeden Fall
bestellt die werden wir jedoch nicht
nehmen sondern den Buttermilch ran
Buttermilch
[Musik]
so eklig ich finde die na ich würde die
immer wieder nehmen
er wird nie wieder normale Nuggets
findest du ja machen wir nun allerdings
weiter mit dem snacksalat Classic es
gibt auch noch einen Caesar Salad bei
McDonald's
[Musik]
doch also ich bin ganz ehrlich
wenn man Autobahn fährt und man will
sich gesund
Salat und Orangensaft ist okay
der Frucht Quatsch meine Damen und
Herren ich glaube das sind pürierte
Früchte 65 % Äpfel 20 % nektarin und 15%
Erdbeeren
macht in den letzten 10%
Luft
er ist nicht mitgerechnet
[Musik]
nein
du musst feiern
wir haben noch zwei Produkte und zwar
den fileto Fisch und die Apfel Tasche
beides Produkte die ich auf jeden Fall
auch schon mal gegessen habe ich würde
sagen wir fangen an mit dem Video Fisch
weil letztes Mal wieder aussieht Alter
[Musik]
der ist top
hätte ich nicht gedacht
einfach probieren
ich bin aus einem Wolken gefallen
allerdings auch schon zum letzten
Produkt für heute und zwar der Apfel
Tasche was du so jemand der so
Apfeltaschen gegessen hat sowas generell
so ein Dessert Mensch bei McDonald's
die sind jetzt nicht an
[Musik]
den Spiegel gucken halt die Fresse du
Lappen an der Stelle würden wir das Luca
serio food Review für diese Woche jetzt
auch beenden als wenn es wöchentlich
wäre wir hatten ein Produkt vergessen
das war die Senfsoße
super passt plant wenn es euch gefallen
hat meine Damen und dann lass doch gern
einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video da
[Musik]
no